to present our next awards one was
nominated for the screenplay of do the
right thing and has written produced
directed and starred in a number of
feature films that have both been
critical and commercial successes the
other has been nominated for Academy
Awards in two major categories tonight
and is the youngest director nominee in
Academy history
please welcome Spike Lee in John's Engel
ttan
this is a 58 Academy is presented to
Oscars documentary films on its
anniversary you want to honor not just
this year's nominees but hundreds of
filmmakers who have through the years
fors the great documentary tradition
from the world of nature to the world of
art but most importantly they record our
common aspirations our common concerns
and our common humanity not to mention
our common conflicts it was one of them
world war ii that inspired the Academy
to begin honoring often unsung heroes
Harold's heroes and heroines of our
profession since then as we'll see in
this montage made up of Academy and
nominated films nothing in our in the
life and times as a gift our eyes or
lenses of art these are recording angels
and these are nominees the documentary
feature limp that following the
footsteps of the previous winners death
on the job
Vince disperse yo and William good talk
producers doing time life inside the big
house Allen Raymond is Susan Raymond
producers
and the shadow of the stars alley light
urban Sarah producers the Restless
conscience hop Nicole half failure
producing wild by law nor it's hot
Diane Garvey producers and he asked goes
to in the shadow of the star Holly light
nerves down
ours is a documentary about the lives of
singers but we can't carry a tune
in fact I think I'm about speechless I
want to thank the Academy I want to
thank our distributor first run features
I want to thank all the people who
worked with us on this film for the
years that he took to make especially
our principal cinematographer Michael
chin in our sound recordist sarah chin I
want to thank the wonderful community of
San Francisco that is so supportive of
independent filmmakers the film arts
foundation with its twenty-two hundred
hundred members Robert Hawke Gael Silva
and Julie maca man they're the leaders I
want to thank Monica lab who were so
kind to us Saul Zaentz and his company
who were wonderfully kind to us I want
to thank the some Cisco Opera Company
Pat Mitchell who opened the door for us
belief in us from the very beginning
when we didn't have anything Lotfi
Mansouri who now guards the Opera
Company but mostly I want to thank the
men and women of the San Cisco opera
chorus who opened their lives to us and
made this film possible and I want to
dedicate this Oscar to all the people in
the chorus everywhere and
a DHS to YouTube in memory
our next category is documentary Short
subject which means a film that is less
than 30 minutes in length and the
nominations are Burton s is a Thielen
aka Shadowhunters Erik Valley and Ilan
made Johnny producers deadly deception
General Electric nuclear weapons and our
vironment Deborah Chad's not producer
little vicious meu Madhu sir the mark of
the maker David McGowan produced it
Memorial learns from American soldiers
build pottery a and Bernard Edelman
produces the Oscar goes to and the Oscar
goes to deadly deception General
Electric nuclear weapons in our
environment never chats not producer
I want to share this wonderful honor
tonight with in fact the national
organization that is campaigning to get
General Electric and all other companies
out of the deadly nuclear weapons
industry in fact supporters all over the
world helped us tell the real story
about the company that falsely claims it
brings good things to life I was very
fortunate to work with a talented
production crew including
cinematographer fawn yaker and editor
Joan Lefkowitz finally I'm very grateful
to my friends and family particularly to
Kim Klausner my life partner who always
had faith in me and to our son Noah who
reminds me on a daily basis of why it's
so important not to give up and to keep
working for peace and justice
thank you very much and boycott GE
in 1979 she won an Oscar of his best
actors for Norma Rae in 1984 places in
the heart Best Actress please welcome
two-time Oscar winner Miss Sally Field
for the first time in the history of
these rights a feature-length film has
been nominated as Best Picture even
though no actor appears on the screen we
members of the Screen Actors Guild hope
this doesn't become a trend though it is
a splendid example of state-of-the-art
M&A animation the film also contains the
dramatic structure charm and even
subtext that are essential to great
storytelling in any form all that plus a
wonderful musical score combined to earn
Oscar recognition for the eternal tale
of Beauty and the Beast